Киянка Олена Калієнко з дитинства
знала про своє польське коріння.
Та лише у зрілому віці,
прочитавши татові листи до рідних, дізналася,
які трагічні події довелося пережити її пращурам
у 30-40 роках минулого сторіччя.
Її діда та прадіда вбили під час Волинської різанини,
інші родичі були заслані в табори або змушені переховуватися.
Мій дідусь був поляком, бабуся українкою.
Вони жили на території теперішньої Рівненської області.
Бабуся Олени попри небезпеку змогла
в радянські часи зберегти польські документи родини.
І ось тепер вони допомогли Олені здійснити татову мрію,
відновити приналежність до польської нації.
В 2007 році Варшава оголосила про виконання свого
морального зобов’язання перед польськими громадянами і їхніми нащадками,
яких після переділу Польщі розкидало по світу.
Головними умовами отримання так званої Карти поляка
є докази польського походження і добре знання мови, культури і історії Польщі.
До прискіпливої співбесіди з консулом
Олена готувалася майже 2 роки.
Пройшла співбесіду з першого разу
Протягом двох років вивчення мови я вже відчула,
що для мене польська майже, як рідна.
Карта поляка дає право на проживання в Польщі
і оформлення через рік після переїзду громадянства,
право на працевлаштування або ведення бізнесу,
медичне страхування, безкоштовну освіту.
За 10 років дії програми процедура
надання карт помітно ускладнилася.
Консульства ретельніше перевіряють,
чи відповідають кандидати усім вимогам.
Адже, судячи з от таких оголошень,
купити Карту поляка в Україні може будь-хто.
Мені щодня телефонують і хочуть купити довідку,
статипросто терміново поляком або полькою.
Навіть доходить до смішного.
«А ви ж Спілка поляків Києва?» Так.
«А чому ви не видаєте довідки?»
Тому що ми не видаємо довідки.
А чому я не можу стати поляком? Ні, не можете.
А чому? Ви ж Спілка поляків Києва!
Чим ви займаєтесь?
Так от, ми не займаємося тим, ми не народжуємо поляків!
Втім, випадків підробки документів не так вже і багато.
Посольство Республіки Польща в Україні повідомилоDW,
що це лічені відсотки у порівнянні з майже сотнею тисяч заяв,
які подали громадяни України за весь час дії програми.
Пік видачі припав на 2009-ийі 2016-ий роки.
У посольстві кажуть, що підписання
Угоди про Асоціацію України з ЄС та впровадження безвізу
не призвели до масової подачі заявок на отримання Карти поляка.
Хоча черга на співбесіди з консулами розписана
вже і на наступний рік, кажуть у Спілці поляків Києва.
Масового виїзду українців з польським корінням тут не очікують
навпаки, власники Картиполяка не завжди хочуть емігрувати.
Це 8 років, як я маю вже карту поляка.
Я скажу так:
їхати на постійне місце проживання
планів таких поки що немає.
От, вона в мене є, це як документ - мій другий паспорт
Олені Калієнко 44 роки,
вона поки не готова розпочати нове життя в Польщі.
Жінка має доглядати за батьками.
До того ж, не впевнена, що зможе
знайти там гарну роботу, в Україні вона держслужбовець.
Тож, Олена просто користується пільгами карти.
Під час відпустки, подорожуючи Польщею,
жінка безкоштовно відвідує музеї і купує квитки
на потяги на 40% дешевше.